Jak patrzę sobie teraz na młodych ludzi
także tych tutaj siedzących na tej sali
to widzę tę cholerną plagę
która dotyka młodych ludzi OD madrytu Po talin
OD lizbony Po warszawę
to jest ta plaga darmowych starzy absolwencji
zastanawiam się
Jak to jest możliwe
że w 2024 w europie
na cywilizowanym kontynencie
na demokratycznym kontynencie
dzieją się takie niesprawiedliwości
dzieje się taki wyzysk
Jak to jest że kończysz studia
masz 22 3
4 lata i idziesz do 1.
2. 4. 7. firmy na 2 3
5 miesięcy darmowego stażu
a potem Po tych paru miesiącach mówią ci
do widzenia mamy kolejnego kandydata
mamy kolejną kandydatkę do pracy za darmo
i tym trzeba się zająć w parlamencie europejskim
jako prawnik
jako adwokat i teraz wiceminister sprawiedliwości
mówię bardzo jednoznacznie
w parlamencie europejskim jest miejsce
na rozmowę o tym i na dyskusję o tym
żeby wreszcie wprowadzić przepisy
które ochronią młodych ludzi przed takim wyzyskiem
i przed takim nierównym traktowaniem